do you think it is possible that this is
the last
season i would think that if this was
the last season of graves
that it would be a whole thing about
tune in for the final season of grey's
anatomy
going back to to you and james and ellen
being the three
og cast members standing have you
ever thought about or do you ever think
about
closing this chapter and moving on to
something else
i know from a creative standpoint there
have been many
like oh this is how the season would end
this is how the series would end
conversations and then they all end up
you know
new because of a myriad of reasons
because
the network's not ready the studio is
not ready the fan base isn't ready the
numbers are too good
i think that collectively they create
they've decided you know what we're
not going to put an end on it we're just
going to wait and see
especially in light of what's happening
right now it's like do we want the last
season to be about coven
or truly wanted you know us to be able
to put some nice ribbons
around it with rainbows and balloons and
things
the promo that we saw for this week's
episode yeah i imagine it's going to be
a very big episode for bailey
we see ben bringing in a patient i think
we hear bailey saying mom
right what can you tell me
yeah well my mom blessed her heart is
having some breathing
issues
i brought my parents um to seattle so
they can be closer to me
trying to be a responsible daughter uh
found you know a
decent i thought you know place for them
to live
but um you know this is seattle right at
the beginning
uh of the pandemic and you know nursing
homes nursing
facilities they were the first ones like
really really hit
so we're gonna delve into you know what
that is
from a medical perspective this one is
close to home this one is a family
member
um you know we we already have our you
know
babies there in the hospital with
meredith and jurassic
so this is another way
that globally we're we're being affected
you did bring up a good point i mean
yeah
a lot of bailey's loved ones are
infected with coven 19
meredith tom potentially
her parents how is bailey doing so i
think we were able to show
starting from the first episode that
what was important to her was keeping
her mental health
on point right not being able to be with
her family
ben even though he comes in for the clap
out
he still is there to ground her keep her
grounded so that she can do her job
um i think we've been able to reveal
especially
you know from bailey's point of view
that this pandemic is just getting
bigger and
bigger and that it's not calming down
at any point a side note i had thought
that by the time these episodes were
airing that we were going to be talking
about the past
this is kind of blowing my mind as an
actor that that that's where we are
she's handling it you know the way that
jesus surgery has the hand let's talk
about her and ben
for a second i think that's one of the
most steady relationships
that we have on the show what's in store
for them
in the next few episodes
yeah so they have been trying to do the
right thing
right which is to to stay separated
being that they're both first responders
and both uh
in you know contact with folks that are
potentially carrying the virus
don't want to put that on their kids but
you know just like everybody else in the
world you get tired after a while
you know we can only be separated for so
long
and you know a plan that theoretically
was supposed to last 15 days
is now you know in its 10th month
so and that's a reality right for for
all of us
out there what do we do in that
temporary plan becomes something more
long-term
so um so uh
so the short answer is i don't know yet
but i do know that it's not gonna last
for ben and bailey
you